On the snow capped mountains of Venus there
is no actual snow as we know it.
Because it snows metal.
And the Lepsis is a designer kitchen pod to
grow your own insects to eat.
Vsauce, Kevin here... this is Mind Blow.
A professor at University of Nottingham, has
discovered a new human body part, a sixth
layer of the cornea.
He is calling it Dua's layer, after himself,
and the discovery means that ophthalmology
textbooks will have to be re-written and clinicians
around the world are already beginning to
relate many diseases to the discovery of this
new layer.
Chinese construction firm Broad Sustainable
Building has been given the go ahead to create
the world's tallest skyscraper called Sky
City.
It is a 220 story, 2,750 foot tall and when
finished will be the size of a small city.
It'll have 104 elevators and a six mile ramp
that can lead 30,000 people towards the school,
hospital, and housing.
And they also plan to construct it in only
seven months!
WiSee is an interaction interface that is
able to recognize human gestures throughout
the home.
Using WiFi and a few mobile devices WiSee
can identify gestures in line of sight, non
line of sight, and through the wall scenarios.
The prototype was able to identify and classify
a set of nine gestures with a 94% accuracy.
And they see it being used to control music,
TV, lights and heating anywhere in the home.
Lego is working with Sony to create toys that
are more like video games to keep younger
kids interested.
Though it's still in the planning phases some
of the ideas are to have the Lego pieces mounted
to small motors and cameras.
The tiny device is controlled with a video
game controller and the enemy devices are
controlled by a computer.
They are woking with having the cameras linked
to a smart device so you can see what your
piece is seeing and are also developing parts
and pieces that can be ejected or blown up.
Worlds oldest primate fossil ever found and
it was the size of a mousee.
University of Minnesota's Biomedical engineering
professor Bin He created a non invasive brain
computer interface that allows the user to
control a robot using only their mind.
Seen here being guided around a gym, turning,
rising, and even flying through balloon rings.
The hope is to use the technology for those
with neurodegenerative diseases to regain
function by controlling artificial limbs or
other devices.
A new reversible male contraceptive proven
effective in mice testicles involves injecting
gold nano rods and heating them up.
So Yeah.
DARPA has created new nerve and muscle interfaces
that can can be controlled directly though
amputees existing nerves.
The project is called RE-NET, Reliable Neural-Interface
Technology and they are hoping not only to
create high performance interfaces that are
reliable, they want to provide sensory feedback
that would also give the user the ability
to feel.
Basically, allowing users to directly control
prosthetics with their existing nerves.
The Emperor 1510 LX is a $21,500 dollar high
tech work station.
It has a retractable monitor stand that can
hold five monitors, a reclining italian leather
seat with thigh rest, Bose sound system, and
a cup holder.
Tokyo has underground bike parking structures
made by a company named Giken that take your
bike into a cylinder that protects them from
theft, vandalism, and inclement weather.
Using a magnetic key for access - the door
clamps onto the front wheel of the bike and
takes it underground onto a platform.
Each station is able to hold about 200 bikes
and Giken hopes to create many more in the
future, but finding enough underground space
in Tokyo could pose a problem.
Finally, Mike Olbinski shot this incredible
footage of a supercell near Booker, Texas
I'm going to leave you with Kilobots going
on a picnic and as always thanks for watching.